hey what's up guys my name is Archana
and welcome back to my figure of blood
theory today I'm going to be talking all
about Turing little and this kind of
extends on from strength which we talked
about last episode if you guys haven't
seen that click on the card or the link
in description below this is just going
to be kind of more of an in-depth look
at what we looked at in that video so
trend literal is basically a there is
characters in between two double quotes
so if we jump in here I can define a
string literal by writing double quotes
and then something in between them such
as China there we go that's a string
literal now what this actually becomes
depend on a number of factors at the
very basic case what this actually is if
you hover your mouse over this is a
contra array of size seven now straight
away you may notice that there's
actually only six characters here right
why is it akancha r87 the reason that
the case is because there is actually
one extra character at the very end of
that string and that is a null
termination character which if we were
to write manually would look like
there's a backslash zero or
alternatively it can just be spreaded an
actual zero and the reason this is
needed is to signal the end of a string
what's trying to a zero not the
character zero if we write the character
zero that actually has a different
numeric value altogether
if you write a backslash zero so that is
what that null character is an actual
numerical zero that's the early signal
the end of the string so if we if we
want to do something like put that back
slash zero in the middle of our string
we would actually break the behavior of
this string in many cases let's take a
look at the standard c library for a bit
I'll just include standard little H
which includes some three functions if I
assign this to something now as we hover
our mouse over this you can see that
it's a concentrate so I might just
assign it to that culture name put it
over here if I put a breakpoint over
here hit f5 like I can inspect my memory
put us in the name of the string which
is name you can see that I'm going to
make this have like 16 columns okay so
you can see that we have cheddar
printing over here we have kind of two
adults here the ASCII representation
which represents the two zeros now the
length of this tree
if you actually count the character
that's going to be 7 because the
backslash 0 is an escaping character
means it just counts as one character
however this is set to a because we
actually have an implicit backslash 0 at
the very end which we have an implicit
backslash 0 at the very end here which
signals the end of our string so if I
want to actually see what my string is
by apps running Stirling which is a C
function which will basically tell me
how long my C string in El Paso named as
my string and we'll see what values are
printed you can see that we actually get
the value 2 reprinting here however
called Cherno is where lobos and 3
characters the reason for that is
because it only counts two characters up
until that backslash 0 because as soon
as it runs into 0 it seems that's it at
the end of the string if we remove that
0 and rerun this code of course we'll
get text which is like the best dream
and not ace which is actually what the
array happens to be right now so at its
core tight this is a comp char array
however we can also assign it to a
conch-shell
pointer that's totally fine the CompTIA
promises that you would be manipulating
the strength so I won't be able to do
something like name to equal a rise
because its marks have comp now if I
removed comps this appears to be
possible and I actually accidentally
said that it was in the previous strings
video however it's not well it might be
it's something called undefined behavior
which basically means that the C++
standard doesn't define what should
happen in this case
so some compilers may generate valid
codes to this but you can't rely on that
so basically this is Bend other
compilers won't even let you compiler
code msps C which is Microsoft's visual
studio compiler which is what I'm using
right now compiled us with no problems
at all
however compilers that is claiming only
I was good and the reason that this is
undefined and not allowed is because
what you've actually done here is you've
taken a pointer to the memory location
of that string literal and threatened
literals are stored in a read-only
section of memory let's talk about that
for a minute
let's jump back into our code I'm going
to open up my compiler settings here
make sure that
on ball configurations I'll go to people
flood and output files and make sure
that this is set to assembly with source
code in my assembler output I'll hit OK
and I'll switch to release point over
here just to simplify the assembly
output and I will build my project next
I'm going to go to the output directory
to this so we have release and we have
main dot ASM this is Amanda if you be
file there for major SM all drivers
individual studios that we could take a
look at be generated assembly go over
here you can see a section called comped
segments and we have this Cherno listed
here what you see here is actually be
identified the laser and the compiler
can actually reason about this trainer
string but the data is set over here to
Turner and there's a contact in hand so
basically this trend is stored in a
comped section in our binary if you open
up the exe file that you get from the
southwest changes occur to do something
a little bit more useful so I'll get it
to print out turn over to the combo that
way we're actually using this string so
when we build this in release mode the
compiler won't optimize away our Cherno
string now if I find the exe file and
open it in something plushes HFD which
is just a hex editor you'll see that we
literally have shadow defined here
inside our binary those characters are
embedded into our binary and when we
reference this is actually referring to
a current data segment that we are not
allowed to add if you do try and add it
to like that even though it'll compile
just fine if you do try and add a code
like this in release mode if I hit f5
you'll see that even though we try to
edit this it actually didn't work the
third character is still EU not a now if
we were to run the same code in debug
mode as soon as we try to actually
execute this code we would get an
exception thrown because you can't
actually do that we're trying to write
to read-only memory if you did want to
modify this for some reason you can you
just need to define the type as an array
instead of a pointer and now if we run
this code we can hit f10 and you can see
it works just fine if we look at our
output here we have Jenna with an a
please never spell it like that devil so
to sum this up you cannot write code
like this if undefined behavior and you
should never do it other compilers will
most likely
warned you about this raven just throw
an error and prevent you can compile a
code like this because you shouldn't be
doing this from season for the webinar
onwards some compile such as clan will
actually only let you compile const char
pointer if you want to compile a child
pointer from a string literal such as
this you will actually have to cast it
into a child manually however MSP
features an inter carrot always been to
fine so basically if you clear code like
this you should really always be
declaring a comped just remind yourself
ignore it you can't actually right click
like this okay similar to fun fact at
our characters we have char of course
everyone by type however there is also
something called w chart under 40 which
is called a white cabbage now let's just
go over this types really quickly so we
have a wide character pointer i'll pull
his name to return is f is equal to
china will get an error because it
actually needs a capital L appended to
the front of it this signifies the
following string literal is made up of
white characters tipis of 11 also
introduce a number of other types such
as child 16 underscore team which again
you will need to set equal to a low-tech
you and then in quote your text
don't forget the pointer and then we
also have a charm 32 underscore t name
for which has an advocate you and your
text you can also define the normal
control one with a u a prefix like this
if you really want to enforce that and
there are compiler setting in which
control whether a char or a WR is used
there are a lot of things we could talk
about again I don't want to really go
into this too long I think this brief
but basically a char is of course a one
byte per character thing a child 16 is a
two bytes per character at 16 bits a
character string and then we have 32
which is 32 bits character or 4 bytes
per character this is basically me to
adhere with with utf-32 this one point
to adhere with utf-16 and then we have
utf-8 which is contra now the question
is what is it what is the
between WHR and shall 16 because they
appear to both be too biased avocado
salsa to both their character now but I
keep saying to about the character
however that's actually up to the
compiler to decide it might be one bite
it might be two bites that might be 4
bytes now in graphic to provide never
seen it to be won by before it's usually
either 2 or 4 it is 2 on Windows and 4
on Linux and I expect Mac as well so it
is a little bit variable if you
definitely want a two by string you can
deal with HR 16 which is always going to
be 16 bits or two by thinking about
weird things to prepare to string such
as UNL you can actually also attend it
things to strength so there is something
in table 14 called FTD's string
underscore literals which give us the
number of functions just for convenience
in the previous video about strings
I wrote code such as this we have a CD
string name 0 equals Cherno and I said
that if you wanted to append some other
string onto this one then you actually
couldn't do that because these are
string literal of course which as you
can see are arrays or pointers so we
can't just actually point it together my
solution was to surround it with a
constructor to basically methods of
string
however since they were 14 there is
something inside the string which were
library which actually kind of makes
that a little bit easier maybe depending
how you look on it and you can actually
just add the letter at to the end of
your string and what this does is it's
basically a function and if you hover
your mouse over G forever you can see
it's an operator
function that actually returns a
standard string now similarly to this if
you were to put you age at the front
that define if you put L at the front
then you get a white string which means
that this becomes a W string and it also
has to be a white string and you can
also do queue and allocates duty to be
able to do things like you 32 strength
for various character lengths so yeah
confuse about strings s are we all one
other thing that we can actually prevent
that string literals is the letter R so
I can write it const char here and I'll
start this off with the letter R at the
front what this means is to ignore a
character
so in practice what it's useful and we
actually haven't have this printed in
here is multi-line string so if I wanted
to have something like line 1 line 2
line 3 line 4 it makes life a little bit
easier because without this we would
have to either do something like this
where we actually append all stuff
together or we could also do on sharp es
equal line 1 and then just simply write
line 2 line 3 you can see that these
don't actually have pluses or anything
in between them and additionally we
would actually have to put it back slash
n onto each of these if we wanted them
to actually be on new line so this is
very common if you want to actually just
write a full paragraph of text or maybe
some code in your code as a string and
you want to be able to define it fairly
easily and this is a lot more work than
just being able to write your code
freely like this so R is a quite useful
and the art after all now the last thing
that I wanted to mention was again about
the memory of string literals and how
that works
string literals are always stored in
read-only memory right always just
because we write something like char
name with an array and we set it equal
to zero and then we decide to change
something like I did earlier and will
print out out to the console if I
actually take a look at the code that
this generates I'll compile it in
release mode I'll open up my directory
here and I'll drag in this assembly file
into Visual Studio will search for
Chenault and you can see the channel
until defining the constant however
we're obviously editing it so how is
that working let's scroll down ok great
here is our function let's take a look
at the code and look at what is
happening we are learning a memory
address over here which is the location
of the name variable now if you look a
little bit up here you'll see we have
name which has an offset of minus 12 is
basically variable that is declared on
the stack again this is getting a little
bit complicated so we'll have videos
about details on this in the future but
for now this is our name variable
basically this address is being loaded
into the EDX register and
we are then moving the Cherno this is
the location of that shadow string
literal in our read-only memory we're
putting that into the a apps register
again if it's a SIDS because the
compiler is trying to do optimizations
here this is release most of my ability
bit hydrators code and then we're
learning ax into that name variable so
what we've actually done here basically
gotten that that Cherno segment and
we've copied it into that name variable
so we've actually created an actual
variable here before if we don't write
this code what we're trying to do is
modify the pointer that points to that
constant data segment so we're actually
trying to write it into the constant
data here is create another variable and
you can see on this line here we moved a
numeric value 97 each that name variable
added offset up to that that's what this
line of code here is doing 97 is the
numerical decimal representation of the
character look at a so that's it Michael
pretty deep hope you understand now how
child pointers and all that stuff works
the train whistle the general it's
really important to understand itself
because you're probably going to be
dealing with strength for the rest of
your programming career as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
you could hit that like button just so
that I know that you liked my video you
can also support this series on patreon
or convalesce the channel if you if you
want to you get some cool rewards such
as DMS contribute to planning of these
videos as well as getting these videos
early sometimes and being drops and all
that fun stuff I'll see you guys later
good bye
[Music]
Oh
[Music]